[Music]
I love my Nintendo switch
I love that I can play it in bed on my
TV
while pooping and of course while
traveling prepare for turbulence oh my
God I'm gonna die and Nintendo loves it
too because here's the thing as mighty
as Nintendo is and Untouchable as it
might seem this thing saved Nintendo in
the console Market
[Music]
1985 the NES releases to the states
despite most stores not wanting to carry
it due to the video game Crash of 1983
it sells it sells so well that it's
estimated one in every four American
Homes has one the world has Nintendo
fever Nintendo seemed Unstoppable at
least that was until
in fact for a while after the NES
Nintendo was on a slow decline Sega
proved that Nintendo could be stopped
and in the states they went back and
forth for who could maintain the highest
market share the NES sold 61.91 million
units worldwide the SNES 49.1 million
then 64 32.93 million and then Nintendo
hit rock bottom with the GameCube
selling only 21.74 million units still
better than the Dreamcast which only
sold 9 million units God I love this
system R.I.P forever
but then something revolutionary
happened the Nintendo Wii
[Music]
the Nintendo Wii was an insane success
for Nintendo it even outsold the NES
selling
101.63 million units Nintendo cracked
open an entire New Market of Gamers with
its system moms and old people
once again Nintendo was on top king of
the world baby this was their hottest
selling system ever and sold better than
the competing Xbox 360 and PS3 what
could possibly possibly possibly
possibly go wrong no foreshadowing
whatsoever here it's not like you read
the title and watched the intro oh my
God it's the Wii U
okay let's backtrack for a second the
Nintendo Wii did sell incredibly well
but that didn't mean it didn't have its
own issues it wasn't as powerful as the
competing Xbox 360 or PS3 and in general
was viewed by hardcore Gamers as a
console casual babies like me played
that was only good for first party
Nintendo games
but why wouldn't you want that many
major third-party developers flat out
refused to fully support the Nintendo
Wii with their latest major games as
frankly the Wii just wasn't powerful
enough to play them and on top of that
the Wii had this weirdo non-traditional
controller all of this led to the
development and design decisions for
Nintendo's follow-up to the Wii the Wii
U because if third-party developers
aren't making games for your system no
matter how big your install base that's
still a lot less money and here's the
thing as successful as the Nintendo Wii
was out of the gate by 2012 before the
Wii U's launch Nintendo posted their
first ever Financial loss as a video
game company yeah that's all great but
the Nintendo we sold really really well
I have an idea why don't we appeal to
both the Casual gaming market and
hardcore Gamers at the same time oh my
God you're brilliant no one has ever
thought of that before
so here was the Dilemma Nintendo wanted
something new like the Wii that would
attract the non-gaming audience they'd
made in Rhodes on with the Wii but they
also wanted something that could appeal
to hardcore Gamers for those sweet
long-term third-party sales so this time
around Nintendo decided on the idea of a
second screen that had a touchpad they
also implemented HD hardware and a more
traditional controller for that second
screen which would evolve into the Wii
U's controller because they wanted to
make it easy for players to transfer to
the new system outside of the Wii U's
main controller the Wii U would use the
Nintendo Wii's controllers so players
who already had a Wii wouldn't need to
buy anything new which sounds like a
great idea
except it wasn't let me explain the Wii
U was announced at E3 2011 with the
focus being on the new controller after
all it was the Nintendo Wii's controller
that made the Nintendo Wii such a major
success right but here's the thing you
got your Nintendo Super Nintendo
Nintendo 64 Nintendo GameCube Nintendo
Wii and now Wii U every other system
before was the Nintendo something new
now you have the Nintendo Wii and
Nintendo Wii Electric Boogaloo it sounds
like a sequel or something
remember how the Nintendo Wii U used the
same controllers as the Nintendo Wii
well between the name the use of the
Wii's controllers and the fact that the
marketing for the Wii U was around its
controller it really made it feel like
the Wii U was just an expensive
peripheral add-on to the Nintendo Wii
you have to remember this was also
around the same time as the Xbox 360's
connect add-on and the PlayStation 3's
PlayStation Move add-on so long story
short the Wii U launched and was an
utter and complete failure despite
Nintendo Land being Amazing Blue what
are you doing regarding the Stars
so let's get into this the Wii U sold a
total of 13.6 million units in this
lifetime
that is just over half of the GameCube
sales
half in fact it's only 4 million more
consoles than sega's ill-fated Sega
Dreamcast this was the worst Nintendo
head ever performed outside of the
Virtual Boy which only sold around 770
000 consoles but that wasn't a Mainline
console I'm not exaggerating by the way
Nintendo was doing that bad but wait I
hear you saying what about Nintendo's
handheld Market there is absolutely no
doubt that Nintendo was the king of
handheld games and it was profitable for
them but Nintendo's a big company with a
lot of operating costs so while they
were making money on the 3DS well back
to the Nintendo Wii U it's launched and
it's doing poorly the Nintendo Wii U
released 2012. Nintendo was unprofitable
from 2012 to 2015. yes even in spite of
the 3DS and don't worry we all love
Nintendo it was wasn't that bad
it was worse by the end of the fiscal
year of March 2014 while the 3DS was
earning a 99 million dollar profit for
Nintendo Nintendo ended up reporting a
456 million dollar operating loss for
the fiscal year of 2014 because of the
failure of the Wii U in operating loss
by the way means the operating expenses
exceeded the gross profits or Revenue a
company made they were doing so poorly
and this is the part everyone remembers
satoru Iwata the president of Nintendo
cut his own pay in half for five months
meanwhile Shigeru Miyamoto took a 30 pay
cut seven other Executives took a 20 pay
cut Mario had to sell his Plumbing
business to pay rent Zelda had to
auction off link to the highest bidding
Kingdom and Samus was busy being infused
with the Metroid and like I I don't know
how she's still alive now before I bring
up the switch I mentioned Sega a few
times for a reason Inception baby it's
because both the Sega Saturn and
Dreamcast in a rocked Albert Odyssey
Virtua cop shining the holy Arc Panzer
Dragoon Power Stone Jack Grime Radio
shenmue grania 2 but despite my love of
the systems they didn't sell well enough
and even though the Sega Genesis was a
king during the 16-bit console Wars Sega
which seemed like a juggernaut
eventually failed in the castle Market
they had to become a third-party
developer publisher to survive as a
company so for Nintendo the question is
were they on track to do the same thing
or maybe sell handheld consoles only and
become third-party Publishers on major
consoles I genuinely don't think they
would have survived another massive flop
before I started writing this video I
knew the Wii U sold poorly I knew about
the famous story of Iwata cutting his
own salary but I honestly didn't realize
just how dire things were I mean it's
Nintendo it's Mario it's Zelda it's the
video game equivalent of Disney it's
it's my childhood and likely many of
yours so when it came time to work on
the switch what did Nintendo decide to
do Nintendo decided to keep nintendoing
instead of trying to compete with the
other big boys of Xbox and Playstation
Nintendo decided like with the Nintendo
Wii they should do their own thing and
focus on making a console that was
unique and both difficult to replicate
and compete against and while the Wii U
was an unmitigated disaster Nintendo
decided to learn from user feedback like
the Wii U is pretty cool except for you
can't play it more than 30 feet away
from the console and therefore I can't
play it while I'm pooping how else are
you supposed to play Advanced Wars but
Nintendo was all about that poop they
got you they took that feedback they
also took a look at the various console
markets internationally whereas Western
audiences would typically play games on
a TV Japanese audiences preferred mobile
game experiences so why not can
connected too I'm sorry wrong console I
mean when you really think about it the
Nintendo switch is basically a Wii U but
fully portable and with far far better
marketing it was definitely a great idea
it was a full-fledged video game console
that seemed next-gen enough could be
docked and viewed on a TV or removed and
portable in a lot of ways it was many
gamers dream just get up and keep
playing the console game you want
whenever and wherever you want I mean
that's why I bought a PSP is because I
found out I could hack into it and play
thankfully the switch changed up its
controller to use joy-cons which while
similar in capability to the wiimotes
were far more advanced I think God it
didn't use the sensor bar anymore
finally there was the third party game
issue while the Wii U had promised
third-party support it was still fairly
lackluster at first and quickly fell off
over time but the Nintendo switch
promised more much more
outs Nintendo switch Nintendo
aggressively pursued third-party support
and Partnerships for the Nintendo switch
and they gave people a splash screen of
companies who were signed on at its
reveal and the fact that from software
was there I mean you can just end the
video everyone was sold and that is how
from software saved Nintendo
seriously Bo this was a big deal
Nintendo was learning from its big
mistakes while also incorporating what
it had learned from the success of the
Nintendo Wii Nintendo also tried to make
a bigger Splash in the Indie scene
making it much easier for Indie devs to
develop on their console finally there's
of course Nintendo games the switch song
absolutely insane lineup from Nintendo
ready for the Nintendo switch's first
year the Nintendo switch released in
2017. also in 2017 you got your Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild and you got
your Super Mario Odyssey that's two
brand new major games in Nintendo's
largest franchises meanwhile you got
your Mario Kart 8 Deluxe released in
2017 a retooling of its Nintendo Wii U
counterparts that didn't sell in fact
basically all of Nintendo's amazing Wii
U games nobody played were eventually
retooled for the switch like 2018 smash
ultimate which is just Smash 4 but with
more or Splatoon getting a sequel in
Splatoon 2 and finally getting his
well-deserved audience so it had the
games both first party and importantly
third party it had not the best but
decent hardware and it had a great
concept around it the only question was
would this be worth cannibalizing their
sales of the handheld Market as the
Nintendo switch basically serves both
console and handheld and well you saw
the title of the video in its first week
the Nintendo switch was Nintendo's
fastest selling console selling 330 000
units in one week in Japan alone
meanwhile in his first year on the
market the switch outsold the Nintendo
Wii U's entire lifetime of sales in fact
the Nintendo switch was the fastest
selling console in first year sales in
both the US and Japan as of the end of
2022 the Nintendo switches sold over
122.55 million units making it the
second best-selling console of all time
only behind the PlayStation 2 and
Nintendo DS's current lifetime sales
that's 121 million 780 000 more sales
than the Virtual Boy hot damn meaning
that could change or not I mean who
knows how long this console cycle will
last financially speaking just months
after the switch's release Nintendo's
stock prices soared to their highest
point in seven years by the end of
September 2017 they'd had their first
truly profitable quarter in a long time
with a profit of 209 million dollars by
Q4 2018 their quarterly profit had
jumped to 956 million dollars even
without a handheld console this
legitimately pumped blood back into
Nintendo ever since the switch Nintendo
has been regularly profitable if the
Nintendo switch hadn't been successful
you have to wonder where Nintendo would
be today I like to hope they still have
a Mario movie and theme park but you
have to wonder if they'd be out of the
console business we might have seen
Mario Zelda Pokemon and other devices
just like what happened to sega's IPS
who knows if they could have survived
another catastrophic failure like the
Wii U and to what extent and that is how
the Nintendo switch saved Nintendo thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed and if you liked it please check
out our previous episodes uh we did one
on the Zelda franchise and one on Sonic
which I I really like those Aha and we
have a Final Fantasy 14 one coming up so
check it out